nous accueillons aujourd'hui fêtera
kenzie et angie est l'auteur d'un roman
jeunesse
échec et mat et publié récemment chez
bouquins bec ici au canada
bienvenue fait comme si en radio canada
international
bonjour et merci pour l'invitation merci
alors fait éclater si vous être
enseignante de mathématiques au
secondaire
comment en êtes vous venu au monde de la
fiction et de l'écriture de romans
donc en fait moi j'ai toujours aimé
écrire depuis tout petit bond aimez
écrire et lire
évidemment depuis tout petit donc j'ai
déjà écrit plusieurs plusieurs heures
par roman mai plusieurs textes et tout
mais que j'ai jamais publié ok mais là
je ressentais le besoin de décrire
quelque chose de partage et surtout
quelque chose
donc l'idée d'écrire m'est venue à
partir de deux raisons principales c'est
les deux raisons la première c'est
j'avais une volonté de partager les
récentes études en éducation notamment
en neuroscience cognitive
donc ça c'était ma première raison
principale je voulais partager surtout
avec des jeunes puis je voulais rendre
ça accessible tout ce qui est fait en
neurosciences cognitives tout ce qui
concerne quand le cerveau je voulais me
rendre accessible aux jeunes à travers
un récit je voulais pas d'un manuel
belle avoue précédé ma question
votre roman raconte l'histoire de sofia
une adolescente de 15 ans qui en échec
scolaire mais qui n'ont qui ne manque
pas de répartie en deux listes
alors afin à la fin de votre moi je les
lui lançant avec beaucoup
d'enseignements sur la gestion du temps
où l'engagement la mémoire la répétition
tout ça on a l'impression d'être en face
d'un manuel de réussite personnelle mais
vous avez choisi la vague du roman pour
toi oui pour gérer j'ai utilisé un récit
parce que pour moi l'apprentissage va
mieux se faire à travers un récit une
histoire à travers à travers le jeu à
travers des enseignements et des
expériences surtout parce que la jeune
sofia le personnage principal vit des
expériences donc
moi je me voyais mal en tant
qu'enseignante montré un manuel un guide
un guide c'est comme disent les jeunes
c'est plate mais dont je voulais je
voulais quelque chose de très pratico
pratique donc j'ai opté pour le récit
puis j'ai moi j'adore les histoires donc
tout ce qui est contre tout et puis
voilà j'ai jumeler les deux l'utile à
l'agréable
alors votre personnage ou bien l'héroïne
de l'histoire sofia va rencontrer tonte
match alors avoir rencontré et elles
vont vivre ensemble pendant quelques
jours je vais pas dévoiler l'histoire
est ce que le rock de tentes match peut
être joué par le professeur dans la vie
quotidienne
parce qu'on peut imaginer que ce n'est
pas que les enfants qui vont avoir la
chance de rencontrer une personne qui va
les guider pendant qu'en mai un stage
personnalisés est ce que les professeurs
peuvent jouer le rôle de tintin c'est
une excellente question
j'aime beaucoup votre question parce que
en fait un enseignant on n'a pas la
chance de faire ses enseignements là en
classe surtout si on a un programme à
respecter
moi j'en sais les maîtres jeu je me vois
mal sortir du cadre et puis aller faire
des expériences de ce journal elle est
en pleine nature j'aimerais tellement
faire ça mais malheureusement je peux
pas faire j'ai un programme à respecter
donc je voulais sortir un peu de ce
cadre-là qui allaient dans tout ce qui
est dans un roman puis une histoire qui
fait revivre des expériences par
procuration a déjà votre roman il est
raconté à la première personne c'est
comme un journal quelque part oui et ça
on vient le on voit un peu le côté
filles de l'histoire est ce que c'est
une histoire qui peut intéresser les
garçons et les filles ou bien c'est une
histoire exclusivement pour filles moi
honnêtement j'aurais aimé avoir un plus
large public là pour le roman mais
en même temps j'ai été aussi dans ma
zone de confort je voulais pas sortir de
cette zone là pour un premier roman
comme ça tout à partager
donc je voulais faire quelque chose
selon mes mains maison de confort
allemand selon votre expérience parfaite
excuse ni filles et les garçons ont les
mêmes différents habits tuellement en
plus des histoires des garçons qui
décrochent milan on est en face d'une
vie qui veut décrocher qui veut aller
travailler parce qu'elle est on est
choquant mathé elle veut plus parler
d'école même si elle a 15 ans oui c'est
vrai c'est vrai que les garçons
décrochent
selon les statistiques évidemment
décroche plus que les filles mais en
même temps c'est une histoire donc je
voulais aller explorer ce côté là où je
voulais c'est ça existe je ne peux pas
dire que ça n'existe pas il ya des
filles qui veulent décrocher iliad est
en fait moi ce n'était pas juste le
décrochage moi je voulais plus m exagéré
le personnage dire que vraiment pas ce
qu'elle veut pas vraiment décrocher on
va dire que l'été réalité dans des
sentiments contradictoires oui c'est ça
mais voilà qu'elle cherchait que
quelqu'un qui puisse l'aider pour sortir
ça c'est tout à fait elle le dit à un
moment je sais ça c'est comme elle sait
pas vous savez la l'adolescence et ses
complexes c'est beaucoup il ya beaucoup
de choses que le jeune que vivre de
contradictions et tout donc j'ai moi
j'ai choisi ce personnage le figa est-ce
que c'est nécessaire à un moment donné
moi je me dis qu'il faut dépasser ce
seuil de cet aspect là d'ailleurs par
rapport à l'adolescence est un moment là
la fille la maman de la fille lui a dit
que l'adolescent ça s'attrape com oui
c'est comme une éclaircie
c'est ça oui jusqu'au bout d'os c'est le
langage très adolescence et les adultes
utilisent beaucoup
selon ge cage là et puis si vous avez
remarqué c'est un langage que j'ai
utilisées et très accessible aux jeunes
épices et leurs mots à eux que j'ai me
j'ai mis sur papier c'est des mots que
les jeunes utilisent donc il le froid de
cette façon leur perception aussi de ski
et l'adolescence ou les partages ce que
l'on sait qu'ils reçoivent comme paroles
aussi des fois nous les adultes on parle
on parle on parle on dit des choses mais
eux ils retiennent certains mots
certains certaines phrases c'est ça qui
retiennent c'est tout donc là des fois
ils réutilisent ces mots exactement les
enfants mais les enfants actuellement
vit dans un monde plein de notification
qui les entoure comment ce qu'on peut
les amener à se concentrer à un moment
où vous dites que les enfants on leur
apprend enfin vous dites que vous êtes
d'accord
vous dites que les enfants on leur
apprend tous à l'école sauf l'écoutent
comment que la ramener à se concentrer
dans un monde qui est complètement géré
par l'identification même nous quand on
a du temps en fait ça s'apprend déjà dès
le jeune âge mois pour les écrans je
trouve que c'est
c'est un fléau quand même qui fait qui
fait mal à la société surtout aux jeunes
puis on leur met entre les mains quelque
chose de deux groupes
quand même un écran de un cellulaire ou
peu importe si c'est très difficile en
tant qu'adulte c'est difficile à gérer
ça imaginez un jeune ont donc moi je me
dis qu'il ya toujours toujours des
stratégies dans la vie ok donc c'est sûr
que si on conscientisent le jeu si on
lui parle il va un moment tous deux un
moment donné trouvé son équilibre
c'était vraiment chercher l'équilibré
dans tout ça notification écoute tout
tout ce monde là qu'on vit actuellement
que les jeunes aussi vive subissent ou
peu importe
il faut trouver l'équilibré ça s'apprend
moi je suis très convaincu que tout
s'apprend alors vous dites que vous
utilisez dans le moment l'expression de
socrate je pense qu'il dit que tout être
humain est perfectible et vous semblez y
croire dans l'autre vous il n'ya pas il
n'y a aucun enfant du côlon peu
désespérée du roman lui il est bien
récupérer non ça n'existe pas ça oui moi
je ne j'ai vraiment une croyance que on
peut se développer on peut et en plus de
ça c'est pas juste ma croyance à moi
c'est aussi les neurosciences cognitives
encore une fois qu'ils en qui démontre
que le cerveau il a une plasticité
donc qu'est-ce que ça veut dire ça veut
dire qu'on peut tout le temps à prendre
se développer ça c'est les sciences
qu'il dise épices et ses récents comme
et yeux dedans moi c'est ça que je
voulais le jeune à l'école par exemple
utilisent sans cerveau ok donc là il
utilise quelque chose il doit savoir
comment l'utiliser
donc je voulais partager ce côté là que
on peut utiliser son cerveau qui en est
tout le temps notre en tissage et puis
il faut être ouvert et puis il faut être
à l'écouté faut être ouvert et à
l'écouté à 702 de base nécessaire parce
que le cerveau et ses places ses
plastiques il est mal c'est que c'est
toujours il est perfectible
effectivement fait comme si vous êtes
l'auteur d'un roman jeunesse
échec et mat publié récemment chez
bouquins bac
ici au canada merci beaucoup merci à
vous